key moment key moment in my career you
know looking back on it there were two
the first was meeting John McTiernan
assistant because she eventually put me
in touch with with the producer who
would hire me as my first directing job
that job ended up not going so well it
was actually a disaster but having that
first professional credit and having
been referred to a working producer from
somebody else he knew in the business
gave me a certain amount of credibility
that I was unable to build on and and
develop further relationships out of
that and then the other moment was for
many many years I had told myself look
if things don't work out I will raise
money and I will make an independent
film myself because so much of this
business if you're a director primarily
less as a writer because there's a
writer you just write something if it's
really good people will see that if they
read it and so the trick is just getting
them to read your script but as a
director you have to direct something to
prove what you can do and often shorts
are just you know ignored by the
industry to a certain extent people for
some reason it doesn't make a lot of
sense producers see a well done short
and they'll in their head the guy yeah
but that's just a short where's your
feature and you know most people don't
have features because they're very
expensive to make and if they're not
very expensive they tend to look like
crap so in the back of my head I always
had this idea that if I didn't break in
eventually and I was never sure what
eventually meant that I would raise
money and make an independent film and I
should have probably done that in my
late 20s or when I hit 30 but it took
another five or six years before I
finally decided that none of these
almost
happened jobs had ever actually happened
and so I should just buckle down and do
this and so that's what happened is
myself and a partner we put together a
business plan we raised 150 thousand
dollars and we made a film and it was
that film that finally got David Lattin
one of the partners at the asylum to
take him seriously even though I'd known
him for 10 years I'd just been a friend
that just been that guy oh yeah that guy
who wanted to make movies but never had
so now I had this thing that I could put
in front of and say here look this is
entertaining people watch this and they
enjoy it and he couldn't deny that and
so you know he put me in touch with an
instructor of development and they
started including me when they were
looking for new ideas and eventually we
we moved on to making a film together
you